six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's try our
caller from the three one four area code
caller from three one four tell me who
you are and jump right into your
question yes Lois I was wondering what
do you think the possibility that Felix
aider or Carter page might be a double
agent slash informant I think the
possibility is reasonably high
I mean Carter Page who I interviewed a
couple weeks ago is the former trump
policy advisor although he as he likes
to say he was just an unpaid volunteer
so yeah I don't get it different what
that makes but yeah I mean he's been
connected to Russia for so long and so
deeply that it wouldn't be shocking to
me Felix aider of course is one of the
other guys who is a Russian American I
believe he's Russian American
businessman who has also been tied to a
number of different Trump projects you
know and it really I'm sorry it really
wouldn't even be that controversial or
shocking to me if they were double
agents like it seems it's it's likely
somebody that was connected to Trump in
some way was probably working for Russia
if not I mean we know that they're in
touch with actual Russians working for
Russia but there were probably people
that they didn't know we're working for
Russia as well okay all right thank you
very much for answering all right thank
you appreciate the call right like am I
wrong that wouldn't be surprising at all
I mean who's your favorite player on the
Boston Celtics David Knight off of this
that's really the important question as
Carter Paige pointed out to me during
our interview